[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et j'ai le
redoutable privilège si privilège il y a
de débuter les taux de tedx ils ont
d'abord mis les seniors en tête parce
que nous avons un but ce qui nous attend
pour nous ramener à la maison de
retraite donc a pas de problème et je
voulais simplement continuer ce voyage
auquel vous avez été conviés et vous
emmener dans mon voyage
ma réflexion c'est un voyage très
lointain auquel je voudrais vous
entraîner ce voyage il y a près de 14
milliards d'années
il y avait ce qu'on appelait le big bang
est ce que d'aucuns appellent le big
bang création de l'univers c'est le
monde de la physique
et puis peu de temps après arrivent les
molécules c'est le monde de la chimie ce
monde de la chimie s'entoure
ultérieurement de membranes ça devient
la cellule c'est le monde de la biologie
nous sommes quatre milliards d'années
et puis il y a deux cent mille ans
l'homme apparaît c'est le monde de
l'histoire et ce monde de l'histoire
c'est aussi celui de la connaissance
parce qu'il ya seulement cinq cents ans
on commence à connaître un peu le
développement de l'homme on commence un
peu à connaître le fonctionnement de
l'être humain et en 1953 on isole une
molécule qui s'appelle l'acide
désoxyribonucléique les son nom de
baptême c'est à dn et c'est ce que vous
voyez ici ce petit flou kullas que vous
voyez c'est la vie c'est la vie qui
apparaît dans nos tubes à essai
et il va falloir attendre quelque temps
pour connaître le fonctionnement
chimiques de cette molécule qui
représente la vie qui représente la
transmission et la question est est-ce
que connaissant tout ce phénomène est ce
que nous pourrons avoir au 21ème siècle
le début de l'immortalité
voilà une grande question philosophique
voilà une grande question scientifique
avant nous les moyens et serons nous
centenaire dans quelques tentes 2030 par
exemple serons-nous un nombre de
centenaires suffisant et bien les
chiffres nous le montre la projection et
que en 2060
nous serons pratiquement deux cent mille
100 points jeudi nous parce que je
l'espère un peu le premier moyen que
nous avons pour aller au delà de notre
vie actuelle c'est d'avoir la
connaissance des maladies et lorsqu'on a
marché sur le gène ongles alors le terme
marché sur le génome décryptage du
génome 2003 2006 on a isolé tous les
gènes humains et on a caractérisé chaque
partie de gênes en se disant tiens voilà
ça c'est une susceptibilité à une
maladie ou ça mais en fait ça sert à
rien 80% de notre génome ne sert
strictement à rien c'est ce qu'on
appelle communément le gène poubelle
sauf que sauf que notre gêne et notre
génétique fait que nous avons 90 % de
similitudes avec le chimpanzé
rien d'étonnant que nous avons 60 % de
similitudes avec la bouche ça ça devient
un petit peu plus étonnant et nous avons
20 % de similitudes avec le champignon
de paris
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'ontogénèse
c'est à dire la descendance que nous
avons et c'est cette molécule qui s'est
formé il ya 14 milliards d'années
elle est là et donc ces maladies nous
pouvons les déterminer c'est ce qu'on
appelle la médecine génétique qui a créé
autre chose c'est la médecine préventive
nous connaissons les jeunes nous
connaissons la susceptibilité à faire
des balles a dit oui mais j'arrête tout
de suite ce n'est pas parce qu'on est
porteur d'un gène que l'on va forcément
faire la maladie attention à cela
donc cette médecine c'est une médecine
qui devient la victime préventive et
vaut mieux avoir une médecine préventive
qu'une médecine de soins
deuxième possibilité technique que nous
avons le traitement des infections
c'est évident depuis fleming on sait
traiter les bactéries on sait éradiquer
les maladies infectieuses
oui mais pas tout parce que la bactérie
a su très bien reconnaître des
antibiotiques et des tournées des
antibiothérapie quant au virus
n'en parlons pas on n'a quasiment aucun
traitement pour les virus et vous
connaissez l'épidémie de hiv de
immunodéficience acquise ce qu'on
appelle le sida ou le virus ebola par
exemple dont on vient de mettre sur le
marché dagueys la vaccination comment
éradiquer ces maladies infectieuses par
la vaccination
c'est comme ça qu'on a vaincu la variole
dès qu'on est en train de vaincre du
moins faut-il l'espérer la polio grâce
au rotary à la fondation bill gates
l'om est peu vaccinés des populations
entières sauf que oui mais les conflits
actuellement ne permettent pas cette
vaccination de masse
troisième possibilité que nous avons
c'est le changement
j'allais dire le changement de pièces
détachées oui nous
vous faire la transplantation oui nous
savons greffer un coeur de savon greffer
un rang 1 fois un pancréas
nous savons le faire oui mais yat-il
compatibilité avec cet organe greffé et
lorsqu'on greffe des cellules de moelle
osseuse
eh bien il se produit quelque chose de
phénoménal c'est à dire que le
grefferont que vous avez introduit chez
la personne déficiente va créer elle
même le rejet de la personne dans
laquelle elle a été implantée
oui mais on peut effectivement guérir de
ce type de maladie
oui mais il va falloir avoir un
traitement à vie pour empêcher le rejet
quatrième possibilité à se faire cloner
mon dieu comme ces boues vous le fait
chaque jour pour les jardiniers vous
n'avez jamais fait de boutures de
géraniums vous faites du clonage alors
il ya deux chercheurs écossais qui ont
effectivement réalisé le clonage en 2003
le clonage d'une brebis magnifique
ils ont prélevé des cellules chez une
mère des cellules de la mamelle de cette
mère et ils ont pris le noyau de cette
cellule qui l'ont transplantée dans un
ovule dans lequel il avait déjà retiré
le noyau et il aurait implanté dans une
mère porteuse
c'est un peu d'actualité je le reconnais
mais bon et elle s'appelle dolly celle
qui est née de ce clonage
sauf que oui mais lorsqu'ils ont prélevé
ce noyau sheila mères donneuses
la mère avait déjà 6 ans et dolly est
morte à 6 ans dolly n'a pas survécu
pourquoi
parce qu'elle avait l'âge de sa mère
donc le clonage
oui mais ce n'est qu'une technique
enfin on sait faire quelque chose
d'absolument extraordinaire et il y a
peu de temps que nous savons que notre
organisme est capable de se régénérer
avec ce qu'on appelle des cellules
souches
c'est magnifique dans mes études et dans
nos études on nous avait toujours dit il
y a deux types de cellules qui ne se
renouvelle pas la cellule nerveuse et la
cellule sexuelle
il ya quelques années de dogmes a changé
et on a découvert des cellules souches
nerveuse et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
cellules souches
c'est tout simplement une cellule qui
est capable de devenir de l'os du foie
du coeur où une cellule nerveuse je
prends l'exemple de la cellule nerveuse
parce que vous avez certainement entendu
parler d'un grand coureur automobile qui
a eu un accident de ski qui est
actuellement en traitement dans un
hôpital parisien paru par un transfert
de cellules souches nerveuse donc
peut-être probablement il y aura
régénération de ce tissu nerveux
oui mais cette cellule souche
aura-t-elle l'information que cette
personne possédée aura-t-elle la
possibilité de connaître autre chose
ne va-t-on pas transformer le
psychologique de l'individu dans lequel
on a transplanté ces cellules souches
vous voyez que la technologie que la
science que la connaissance peut nous
amener à faire beaucoup de choses et que
le dernier point sur lequel je voudrais
un petit peu orienté ce ce début de tedx
c'est de dire que
dans notre matériel génétique celui
qu'on a vu depuis le départ il y a un
petit fragment dans l'aube ou de
chromosomes ce qu'on appelle les
télomères
qu'est ce que c'est que cette partie
télomérique c'est la partie au jaune que
vous voyez ici cet article homérique
elle est chargée du contrôle de la
division cellulaire
parce que tous les jours à tous les
moments à toutes les secondes
notre système de cellules se divisent
mais sont sous contrôle
ce contrôle de cette partie télomérique
et 7 ce contrôle c'est le correcteur
orthographique si vous voulez de
certains logiciels
lorsqu'il ya une erreur c'est la partie
des lots mérite qui agit et qui vient
corriger l'erreur qu'ils viennent d'y
avoir de là à empêcher les fautes
d'orthographe
c'est une autre paire de manches et
cette partie télomérique on s'est rendu
compte dans des études chez des
personnes centenaires que cette partie
télomérique était un petit peu plus
grande que les personnes d'un âge
canonique
elle était donc centenaire et à
l'arrivée un l'âge de 100 ans
parce que leurs télomères était un peu
plus grand vous me voyez venir l'élargît
sont notre espérance de vie
élargissons nos télomères et ça c'est
l'immortalité
et oui mais si nous faisons cela nous
allons donner la réplication cellulaire
c'est à dire la division cellulaire de
façon totalement anarchique plus de
contrôle de la machine plus rien ça
s'appelle une tumeur
vous voyez que notre riz mais à chaque
fois chaque technologie nous avons ce
type de problème alors c'est vrai que
nous sommes à la limite de la
philosophie à la limite du
transhumanisme je voudrais simplement
conclure ce toc
par cette phrase que l'on doit à
françois rabelais 16e siècle science
sans conscience n'est que ruine de l'âme
et que un chanteur beaucoup plus proche
de nous alpha blondy pour ne pas le
citer a repris cette phrase et la
transformer en science sans conscience
n'est que ruine et l'arbre je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]